like welcome to the iron Lord fire
episode number 52 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day we've got a
very special guest Xbox and Sega rumors
state of decay - price drop January NPD
Phil spends his speech switchport rumors
and Xbox one x parity to discuss so we
gonna get around into it I want to
introduce the Lord whose quality content
and unbiased approach to gaming deserves
much-needed recognition at the
roundtable similar to the ILP this
Lord's passion for destiny and
multi-platform gaming is evident in
everything he does from its indie
spotlights in Let's Plays all done with
tremendous dedication and grading
introducing the co-founder and producer
of the short pause gaming podcast the
tick Award nominee for the best podcast
of 2017 and the Lord who always will
remind you what hunters are the master
race making his debut in the realm of
the Lord's mom made Lord don't 79 how
you doing sir I am great first of all I
gotta say this I got a serious this is a
big-ass table now when you guys talked
about this round table I appreciate you
guys having me on yes and as you
mentioned I've been following the iron
Lords podcast ever since we lost to you
guys for best show and I just want to
tell you guys since I started listening
the thing I dig about your show is the
positivity you guys focus on the games
you guys focus on the news and you leave
everything else to the side and I dig
that about you guys know so many
podcasts right now can kind of like edge
towards that negativity and focus on the
negativity you guys focus on the
positivity and I'd really really admire
that so it's a pleasure to be here and
thanks for having me on much much of
meetings a lot I've been talking for a
little bit trying to work out the
schedules to get get the dual or dude
himself on the show so what you guys are
doing out there man huge huge fan of
show up boss man you know I tried to
sneak in your let's plays and your
spotlights as much as possible I really
like what you're doing it on like you
said I mean just always want to support
the positive people in the community
yeah shout out to a lord piccolo love
Micra strike Lord bender of course we
have the four horsemen of gaining those
usual suspects at the round table I'm
suing my co-host with the code most will
be joining us in progress he will be
getting off work so I don't think he's
in just yet but of course we have our
most technical gaming law the solo game
experience and also the Lord of all of
the court some of it this morning
sporadically but I like King Live with
that I'll jump in up on what I know that
I saw of course we have the excess gave
the Lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than a premium
experience and is the tiki torch
extinguish wrestling yeah you know the
floppy guys that come out early why you
get your popcorn and stuff together and
then I'll do you like you're that guy's
kind of nice I don't even know what his
name is but so champ each AK he's nice
I saw yesterday you know they threw
together the the Battle of the unknowns
now I'm never disrespecting anybody to
put on those gloves there go into that
squared circle to get it on
trust me you risk your life every time
you go through oh those ropes every time
you put that mouthpiece in every time
you slap it together and you touch hands
and you commence in combat snow no
disrespect to anyone that fought last
night it was a battle of the unknown
foreigners I've never seen the card that
had every person from every square of
this earth I mean I'm talking about
remote places fighting from Cambodia
[Applause]
last night I mean yes some good fight
she's had so check D check versus and
they got it all last night
but let me tell you something next week
it's the big fight you have the
heavyweight champion of the world
fighting is number two mandatory King
Kong that's going to be a great fight
and then you have the washed up light
heavyweight champion of the world that
Andre Ward washed him up and made him
quit though Kovalev oh look the crusher
the tiller the racist subjects but he's
openly racism so we pretty much you know
you know what it is I'm hoping he
bounced back I want him to get to the
the highest form of his mountain so you
fall harder so I'm praying for him to
win next week so he can actually fight
somebody worth married um but to MMA we
have a little bit of a controversy last
night I saw a great MMA match I saw a
clean fighter fighting another clean
fighter I saw beautiful headshots
bodywork ground-and-pound name then at
the end the MMA communities in the other
world you please have to enlighten me on
this because I saw what I thought was a
really good match it was until the legal
kick to the head did be lost loved ones
it was a grazing news but it was Jeremy
Stephens oh god what is your Emmett
Emmett right all right and Jeremy
Stephens is a beast like his his
nickname is little heathen and that's
exactly what he it's like he is a mom
and he it was a good fight up until that
point of Steven's caught him with a left
hand dropped them and just swarm
um he dropped a bunch of elbows to the
side of the head the last one might have
grazed the back of her head that I
didn't feel to be so egregious but when
Emma tried to get up and Stephens he
kinda he held his head and swung and and
lifted his knee up to hit him while both
of his knees were still on the ground
when your opponent's knees are on the
ground and you try to kick him to the
head that is an illegal hit at least one
foot has to be he has to at least be off
of one knee right so yeah that was an
illegal hit it was grazing it didn't
catch him flush but uh so that's where
the controversy is after that um Stephen
continue this war mommy hit him with two
elbows um basically from top position
and knocked him out and that was that um
but you know it's one of those things
like in the moment I don't think
Stephens meant to do it intentionally
he's just an animal like that that's
just his fighting style and it was on
the ref to see it you know it was kind
of blatant though it was blatant that's
the only it was so blatant in the moment
that the ref not seeing it hmm daddy did
it I've been listening in all fairness I
mean it was very what's the world like
it was very bambam it was kind of like
so I kiss based on what I saw I can't
say that you know little heathen had
deliberate intention though school pride
rules for what I think I think his name
is causing the controversy young
pacifists
a lot of negative connotations now I
think he shot at the title I think he
deserves a shot at Holloway but there
two people still in front of him
but I think he's the one that's shown
lately he's ready for it he's been in
the company for a long time without a
shot so yeah I say Danny give me the
shot like I want to see that fight yeah
absolutely absolutely
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so you'll
get into these games but before we get
into what the Lord's not playing this
week I want to start off with Lord old
his video game system history
his passion for destiny and of course
would let him to the creation of the
amazing short pause gaming podcast so
Lord do let's start out with those video
games it was like the first systems yeah
let's start for the beginning the one
that I I know that I had first was the
Intellivision I remember it briefly I
just remember we had it but I think it
was it was the Nintendo when it launched
you know Super Mario Brothers jumping
into that that's when I first got my
experience with video games duck hunt
rygar were all games I loved spending
time with so I was born I was a Nintendo
child growing up
never never really dabbled with Sega I
know it's not gonna be a popular opinion
right here but I did leave the realm
already until the Dreamcast game around
the Dreamcast came around and it changed
my opinion of Sega very much I love the
Dreamcast thought that was a great
system and then after that just went to
the PlayStation 1 PlayStation 2
PlayStation 3 um in terms of games I
like to play I was mostly a sports kid
growing up I loved all sorts of sports
games and just about every one of the
platforms you know started with senja
10-yard fight on the Nintendo
but what to like you know it was good I
think John Elway football was another
good one that I got into and then Brett
Favre NFL football for the Nintendo 64
was really really good but I think the
one that changed me forever was NFL 2k5
that is still my football game ever made
I love NFL 2k5 and then after that I
kind of went away from NFL games a
little bit didn't looking a man but NCAA
football changed my life and I still I
still blame NCAA football for failing
multiple classes in college okay
when NCAA footballs are introducing
online like leagues that's when things
got really bad like really bad because
my brother would be recruiting the same
player that I was recruiting I was like
okay look I got an exam an hour but I
know he's pushing hard on this dude I
was like I'm not gonna take the exam I
got to work on this year so I would go
to my rod oh I'm telling you dude it was
fierce as my brother my cousin a couple
friends it was fierce and I would skip
class to work on recruiting so I blame
NCAA football for my GPA everyone loved
bo Jackson that was great I was a
Christian to koi a fan for the Chiefs oh
that was a lot if I wasn't playing as
the Lions because those were my boys I'm
a Lions fan unfortunately I hate to
admit that but okay my blood is green
thorn too just because you see the Hall
don't think my blood is
so I mean it was it was mostly sports
growing up my friends that were very
competitive in that regard
NBA Live 97 one of the greatest
experiences my life was my best friend
we during like towards you into the
school year we were like alright look
dude we're gonna do a best-of-seven
series my pistons verse your bowls and
at the time I had like Lindsey Hunter
and Grant Hill squad and we were playing
for two big bites at 7-eleven playing
for two big bites and I remember dude it
was game seven and our friendship almost
ended mind you Game seven Lindsey Hunter
in the corner fadeaway three with three
seconds left brains it get my big bites
and dude every time I stopped at
7-eleven and I go to get a bit a big
bite much to my doctor's chagrin I sent
my buddy a text of me and I just go man
this thing tastes really good oh you
said finger emoji back 20 years ago and
I remind him of Lindsey Hunter the
greatest three-point shooter of all time
I think player 99 who's Jordan on the
question that NBA lab wasn't that the
first like I don't say like 3d slash
kind of isometric used to go like
diagonal right in it I do remember that
but I believe this one we played it was
side to side herbicides going back think
you could change something that's the
same way that you say that because this
was seriously podcast we have some
horrendous bets just in the same vein of
that beautiful bet that you have put up
and I love you right
and then like I said you you said you
went all into PlayStation now in between
time I just want to ask you I've got a
couple systems shut down oh you didn't
you didn't really say kid you kind of
Nintendo through and through so I'm just
when you stayed in that ecosystem 64
GameCube that kind of bit actually I
stopped at the game or at the 64 I never
made it over to the game key which I'm
disappointed by because there were so
many great games that came out thank you
it was very difficult for my have my
parents like grab all these different
all these systems for me and I was a kid
so I was pretty humbled with just having
one system and then when we went to the
Dreamcast you know that kind of set me
up to go to the PlayStation after that
so I never made it to the Gamecube but
before was my last one crazy sound like
you like muffled like you know it's not
like you in a cave all right so you got
to get everything poppin then we moved
over PlayStation all that good stuff
now did I was Xbox one ever part of your
ecosystem well or did you jump in with
your 360 or no no Xbox systems until
later yeah the first one I owned was the
360 I grabbed that one I think it was a
Call of Duty world or a Call of Duty 2
was the big title for it when it
launched and I really enjoyed that
thought that was like my first time with
an Xbox prior now continuo dude but at
the time no my the Xbox one is my first
like real like jump into the Xbox
ecosystem to really be able to
appreciate a lot of the games that that
have come out on the platform like III
feel very fortunate that they did the
Master Chief collection and then they
did the the gears of war games he'll
remaster one or that I'm sorry the
ultimate edition of the first Gears of
War being able to go back and experience
these games that missed last gen was
very beneficial and I really appreciate
that so I've grown to like really enjoy
the Xbox side of things in terms of
their exclusives and their games and
being able to play the games that I
missed in the pack
nice absolutely man cool cool so let me
ask you want to cut your arm what about
put you on the spot
top five Lord dude game franchises your
personal favorite games it could be a
franchise don't have to be like a
specific you know title but this man put
me on the spot trying to cope here some
of the ones that really just the
franchises well I have to say Mario
Brothers I split I spent a lot of time
playing the Mario games when I was
younger those were very influential and
giving me into gaming to appreciate
gaming those those the Mario games were
very very big and then I'd have to say
after that at the NCAA football games I
spent a lot of time playing NCAA
football I really loved those media
games and thought those were the best
football games out there so I loved it
and then uh you know I think what else
was really impactful Uncharted games I
really enjoyed that because that was
like Chris and I played games that were
very heavily story driven very well done
so I really enjoyed that but I mean you
know it's hard to nail five but I'm
gonna say probably the most influential
game the two most influential games for
myself the first one was so calm too
because that was my first and I mean
seriously that game consumed me I loved
that was my first time hopping online
playing online multiplayer and my cousin
a couple my friends and buddies we
started playing I mean that's that's the
game like to find the all-nighter for me
nice on an 8 p.m. and we were just next
you know it's 4 a.m. dude I was like oh
my god being able to play the friends
who weren't in the same city or my
brother who had just moved away for a
little bit being able to play with him
and bring us all together was really
awesome and then I think the other ones
probably destiny because destiny was
just um that's one of the that games
like built on basically what I got from
SOCOM you know there's a multiplayer
game that brought me together with not
only my closest friends but other people
new friends like Frankie viper strike
I met Bend around there a boys boys
piccolo 9:30 he's a big fan just the
community of the first destiny was so
strong and I actually loved how much
stuff there was to do I spent a
ridiculous amount of time and destiny
and that's probably one of the big most
influential games of my life as well
nice we you literally
just led into my legs lotta question it
was about that that's leave passion and
it's farmers like I would let you guys
kind of cuz you cut a girl it was in the
same vein as us in the sense that your
foundation actually kind of started out
with desti so you talked about that
community and stuff like that so that's
that's cool yeah you actually let right
into it so now the next question I have
for you is reference to the short pause
gaming yeah what led to that whole
creation you guys forming up and how did
that whole process start uh well it
started before the short pause I um I
had met some guys that I was writing
reviews on a tumblr I think it was I was
just just kind of getting into writing
reviews talking about video games there
and I came across some guys are running
a podcast called play nation plus and I
was like okay and they saw my review for
a game like hey you want to be on our
podcast yeah I'll try it out and to see
what it's all about and how much bad yes
and you know being able to learn kind of
the ins and outs of running a podcast
and and all that jazz was like I really
do like talking about video games
because these guys I met up they were
very passionate gamers and then I saw
the way podcast and you could reach out
to other gamers and talk to them about
games like man I really enjoy getting
together with other gamers talking about
games talking about how much they mean
to us and stuff like that
and so once play nation plus kind of
like it kind of slowed down and guys
started going though separate ways about
he I work with we start talking about
hey let's try let's try doing a website
let's see what happens okay and so it
kind of spawned in 2014 and my buddy at
work he was good friends with boys
piccolo 9:30 and we all came together
and said here man here's how here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do this this
this and originally a pod cat our
podcast was like bi-weekly and we
weren't even sure if we were gonna stick
with it you know we're just like man
there's a lot of work that goes into
this and Boise was like man we should
probably go weekly and I was like I
don't know if we have the time for that
because I don't know if you guys know
our show is not short and so we went to
weekly and we just started kind of
building an audience and and you know
once we got to the website portion down
we went to the podcast and then it kind
of evolved into a video podcast and you
know it's basically this may our website
we just were like look we're not we're
not journalists
we're not media we're just gamers and
that's the one thing we always try to
keep in mind
we create content we don't want to come
at it like journals and you know we have
inside scoops to try to do stuff we're
just gamers and we want to talk about
games for gamers with gamers and that's
like always been our mission statement
just we're gamers talking about games
and it's been a lot of fun it's been
it's been an awesome experience I'm
watching the podcast evolve and trying
to improve it as best we can and on a
weekly basis it's just been an
incredible learning experience and I've
learned a lot of stuff when it comes to
like producing videos and producing a
podcast it's just it's it's it's a labor
of love I mean it can take up a lot of
time a lot of my time and you guys know
this it takes up a ton of your time but
when you idea what it takes
oh yeah and but we love doing it it
doesn't matter you just nailed it it's
when you you have that passion and
sometimes I'm actually writing sure that
I'm just like smiling laughs I can't
wait to do this to see what people go to
respond and just the interactions and
stuff like that so you just nailed it
it's it's a lot of work it's a lot of
dedication but which one you love and
you have that passion for it doesn't
feel as much as work podcasts are really
fun until you know spending a whole
weekend playing blood-borne then the
frustration starts the mod know the
whole game I didn't really frustrate
like it really frustrated and to the
last boss like I literally was like I
gotta get off here like I'll talk to you
guys in a couple hours I need to calm
down the difficult game conqueror of the
young wolf Bobby Lord with the good
microphone you do exist I think what
happened is it registered my uh my
headset that I'm wearing and not my
snowball so I've disabled got other
headsets so it was like you can't use
this this is not working
this is not the preview experience yeah
yeah I had a decent weekend I played
like probably 12 13 hours of blood-borne
and streams it was very rough
it's okay let me get this straight here
okay mm-hmm people who out there saying
blood-borne is hard calm yourself down
Dark Souls is way harder than blood boy
me shots fired
it was only like two bosses that had be
like what is going on like I have
awesome dude under his seat with a bunch
of spiders he had me lit for a couple
seconds but after I figured I had a five
most like this dude ain't nothing ok the
last boss I felt like the only people
that gave me problems was people with
guns we can they see man this [ __ ] out
of guns yes have you sitting there
beautiful combo he hits me like three
times of a shotgun I'm like dude that's
enough dude that's enough what are you
doing how many bullets is in the shotgun
like serious dude dude the last boss had
a shotgun did you torture yourself like
that to live so you can watch you play
but kid smooth has to beat the game now
so I said eh I don't know how that's
gonna work cuz you know those art kids
lose games at all like you know and he
was like well you know there's a bet
going on right now that if he beats that
he gets $400 okay he has 50 hours or he
has to do before III Wow I was like kid
come on you're not even looking about
the people like the money you're gonna
make off the strings it's like would you
be the money I'm gonna make off streams
I was like dude over a thousand people
watched you play Disneyland you're good
like let's be really yes I sorta get to
finish that with a lord dude we've
finished knit with the short pause
gaming podcast creation and we're just
talking about how difficult it is to get
stuff going at first but um you got the
passion going and did so again you guys
you all I just want to go like to
clarify the meeting of all four of you
cuz I believe I tried bender piccolo and
yourself as well there's a fifth guy Ted
is a secret yeah that's he's he's kind
of like the wizard behind the curtain he
takes care of the website he does the
website stuff you'll make sure it's up
to date but he also covers a lot of
anime for us nice so he's on the team or
handles
the anime for and he's helped out with a
couple of video games you know but he's
more into the anime and he still handles
that but he's mostly kinda like the
webmaster takes care of the site dad
yeah better consistently like you guys
been doing it like I said I try to pop
in as much as I can I see the nightfall
stuff I saw when you guys did a 9
parchments I was actually interested in
that game you guys did like a little
logic with that and plus I got a shot
the mouse saw they had the woven blade
in these flat like - yes I like that you
give little titles and big titles oh and
shout out to um you guys for the UM the
Kingdom Come deliverance interview that
you had with the community management
leaves Rick yeah that was fantastic I
was a great job I really liked that you
know you guys sat down with them you
know ask the questions and didn't like I
said just nice quality having the game
play going on in the back and stuff like
that was the one thing about the
interview is it probably should have
been 20 minutes longer mm-hmm we had all
sorts I mean okay just quick story here
and I'll stop by this is like part of
the problem with not problem with the
difficulties of podcasting yeah we were
using them too we were using YouTube to
talk to Rick and know to grab all the of
the audio and what now we captured off
of you or off of um Skype right so
during you know anytime we record our
podcasts no issues skies andrew freezes
software never freezes up everything is
beautiful
anytime we're gonna develop her on skype
just says you know what I'm gonna buckle
under the pressure and the same thing
dude if you watch the video you can see
Rick's hat changes because we Skype
froze up the software froze up so we had
to restart and then we started again he
changes his hat and then it froze up
again was that right to stop everything
and then once we got the Skype call
everything back up
we started talking again dude I forgot
to hit record 20 minutes a good
conversation I'm sitting there talking
to them we're having a good conversation
I look up and I noticed that red lights
not a babe
could always see it in the interview
just see this blank look on my face
realizing that I just started recording
out you just see this look up like I'm
an idiot I am so mad right now
we've all got horror stories trust but
nonetheless it was a great interview
with Rick Rick is an awesome guy he's a
very passionate very high-energy guy and
it's nice to be able to get developers
on that's what we like to do that work
because like I said we're not developers
we're not we're not media we're not
drones we don't know how this stuff so
the best way for us to tell our audience
and like you guys as well when you get
developers on is to kind of like just
give your audience an inside look at
game development it's not as you know
sometimes when you read or when you look
at comments or when you do a podcast
people talk about games it's always so
as quick as like you hear things like
the devas lazy or you know they can
afford this they can afford that it's
when you bring these developers on that
when you learn the information behind
the scenes and you know it's not as
simple as a lot of gamers think it is
that's does the biggest misconception is
that gamers think they understand what
goes on with development you don't know
anything until you run to a developer
talk about it it's so much that goes
involved and there's so much things as
far even with patching stuff of that
nature like no we're talking on Mina box
we do it that's the kind of flashpoint
that deep dive and people have no idea
hey why don't they just change is it so
simple right
understand is sometimes just that one
change affects so many other systems
that are lie it on said change so you
have to be careful Don them these things
have to be tested again we're not trying
to say here make excuses involves the
developer you know say all the time but
at the same time people have to
understand how difficult things are it
is not easy and these guys put
themselves on the front lines all the
time to get blasted by the community and
I you know the fanboys why don't you
doing out here we go get into what the
Lords have been playing already seeing
that Lord Attica already jumped into the
blood one pain that he went through but
um uh man just a lot of Kingdom Come
deliverance I tell you what man that's a
pool
rising title right now it's it's very
divisive there's a lot of people that
are disappointed with it and you know
it's so difficult with games like this
because I understand why people are
upset and for and there are times where
if I get a game and there are issues
with it I'm upset but when the quality
of the game the story when everything is
there and you know what it can be that
can make it a little bit easier to
swallow the pill of like you know a bug
here a bug there and I mean that I love
Rick and I love or her studios but there
are some issues with this game you know
nobody's denying I mean flat at the same
time when you hop in there and play this
game for myself I enjoy the story I love
exploring the world the combat is not
easy but once you do get the hang of it
and once you rank Henry up and he gets
different abilities different works it
becomes very very exciting and you want
to keep playing it so I think that's a
testament to the game despite its
imperfections I want to keep playing it
and that's what makes this game special
in my mind because it's it's almost
there and that yes and it's extremely
ambitious this is this is a small very
ambitious that's working on a set budget
they got from Kickstarter so I mean when
you look at the potential just imagine
what's gonna happen to warhorse when
they get the back when they get make the
money and they can go on and make a
proper big triple-a game I can't wait to
see what these guys do next
I'm absolutely - yep I'm with you I want
you to Laguna I'm completely I've got
it's so ambitious I love the system I
mean this game I was getting sleepy by
the character that his eyes are flashing
what's going on then one time I overate
and I saw a little fat pig I can this
game is crazy it's just so many little
things and I was just running around and
I got dirty and that was it you know
people don't want to talk to me and they
Marchant want to sell me intricacies
just even down to the food like you get
hungry and I had a whole bunch of food
on me I was trying to like a long trek
out running around in the wilderness and
like I had to really check the full
because some of the exploration on it
was really low and I should have had
foods that had you know long expiration
that didn't spoil because that would
affect you as well so it's like this
deep ultra-realistic Skyrim no magic no
dragons
is real combat great story I go I really
like what they do now is it there's it
dumb bugs yes is it some jank yeah but
it's just so I just felt graphically I
have one xbox one exit mmm so I hear
what you going with that
so definitely Kingdom Come deliverance
is on the list I hear ya Oh Lord solve
what have you been playing this week on
xbox I've been playing some Assassin's
Creed origins finally finally almost
cleared out the map so now I'm finally
like go into the story got to the point
yeah like you know they were the
beginning of the quote-unquote assassins
kind of happens it were not very cool
got intriguing kind of story up so I'm
excited to finish that this week I was
watching Mad Max fury road and I said
you I got to get back to Mad Max man
because that's that is a very
underappreciated game on on this
generation of consoles like it's an
open-world it's kind of it there's kind
of not a lot to do in comparison to like
a GTA or or an assassin's creed even but
kind of supposed to be that way it's
like a it's a barren wasteland
so they lean into that very well um the
combat is like you know Arkham style
combat the game is really fantastic it's
kind of bland overall like it's not a
ten it's like a 7.5 but it's a solid
solid so I got back into that for a
bunch of hours just cleaning out more
than that and then I'll switch Bane out
of one and two just cold you pick the
mob yeah I got them both so yeah man
those game from beautifully handheld
mode doctor guys I mentioned it last
week it can get a little muddy but still
looks pretty good but I still prefer to
play them on handheld mode gotcha um and
instead I've been talking about this
game for a month man but Celeste man
done ringing Celeste
let me be clear I suck at platformers I
decided I've always sucked at
platformers whether its lack of skill or
lack of patience Oh Lord kabobs who got
all your platforming ya know
hey brother guy and that's the thing
like living you know growing up in a
house with like a savant for those games
like hi box appears I'm like yeah kibosh
it was kind of like you'll finish and
you'd be like I don't like that game
every stage has what they call a b-side
writing and the b-sides
are like super super hard so I just got
passed as a part that you're in a hotel
right though that that's into Mia what
I've heard that's one of the most
difficult parts of that game is the
hotel especially the b-side and I got
through it
and I was so high use any cheats like
the way it brings you right back in
after you died doesn't really that you
have a chance to think about it your
fingers were in pain but I loved it I
loved the twenty dollar game get that
game anybody who has a get that game I
see someone in the comment section
saying that game you guys are talking
about it's harder lockpicks harder than
blood-borne cuphead and dark look when
it comes to lockpick lockpick no
lock-picking that's it's your RPG if
anyone on those there I would say cup as
the hardest one from those just because
if you don't come in there in a debt you
just grew there's no leveling up you're
just screwed at least born then Dark
Souls and you know deliver it's like if
you start getting old it's like oh I
gotta go do some other stuff before I
come back on one cuphead if the devil
killing you the devil is just gonna keep
killing so you didn't pick up Celeste on
on the switch an attic adding them such
a dis which lately I don't think I don't
even know no I did celebrate
you find it on the switch not looking
for your child Obi don't do that game is
that games incredible Lord summers I
played that on the switch I've been to
the summit yeah it's it's a fantastic
game everything that game is awesome
gameplay is tight
the music is exceptional the story is
actually very very good so les is
probably my favorite game this year it's
not the cop would be confirmation like
everyone's raving about I gotta check it
out I'm working on a play but I'm we
gonna get in the Lord King where he's
playing and
and has been going down what's going on
oh you know III listen to you guys and
I'm sure like who are you people
he's like yeah I was playing I'm getting
texts I'm getting tweeted I'm getting DM
I'm told is ringing they let your
where's this pub G game play shout out
the punch
shout out to breath shout-out to Vogel
shout out the hot monkeys
shout out to the whole squad it's got to
the point shout out to death you got to
the point that we're running two to
three teams in one chat playing
different games with one man out if yeah
but see stay wait they wait for you to
say something like um I'll be right back
I gotta go to the store or oh man I just
logged on something happen to my system
oh well we'll jump right in part is mine
like jumped in it's like let's go shout
out to a Bostonian last night I was
teaching them technique C and probably
there's three techniques right and this
technique is rock that's when you land
you grab a car and you shoot to the
middle of the board and you hunker down
Luke there in the center with it we
think the board is gonna shrink that's
right
then there's paper paper is where you
land you loot and you come in slowly as
a circle comes in mmm dad that is
traditionally the most common right your
team is coming in came up with these
names this this boy is called scissor
this is the most aggressive because you
work in teams of two
whoa first team drops in the beginning
of the board second team
at the end of the board and you work
your way in a pincer like technique
coming in so you can get the enemies in
the kill box if you're all can make it
to the middle with that technique you
gotta have severe patience because if an
enemy run past you don't engage mm-hmm
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get them all in that
trajectory where they're paying
attention to what's going on over here
and not understanding that you have
another team that's behind them actually
get them to kind of beef with themselves
what we're talking about now is like I
took with you law cognero I've been
playing this game so much that I'm just
gonna start streaming it because the
conversations that we have are
ridiculous now I understand there's two
different types of King David the first
type of King David we confirm that you
have a split personality oh yes yes
severe PI bowlers the separatist brain
whatever you wanna call it
this dude is actually two entities in
one is David Banner and this is the Hulk
right David Banner is what you get here
I can give my children to talk to about
what they friends in school because they
listen to the podcast at lunch and then
there's me okay that's the guy that is
saying those words that can't be
repeated here that is giving those
chicken dinners with his squad and
there's yelling there's Nigerians in the
room if you understand what I'm saying I
want you to understand when you see the
screen please don't report us I still
pop G on my cell phone
did you see it it's coming out yeah it
looked amazing
shout out to the razor foam I might have
to switch allegiances
you know today's phone because that that
razor phone looks like it's the best
gaming cell phone I've ever seen
maybe it's the iPhone maybe Samsung that
razor phone looks great I'm so pumped G
in a stripped-down version on a cell
phone
I'm sitting there like I need that in my
soul while I'm at work yes and as we go
get it to that we could guess about that
no doubt I found it so you guys can
leave me alone he was it was it was
malnutrition in the go to work so we can
talk about snow it's always in that bag
I was referring to the rod be an issue I
think I might have to like look around
this house for the charger pretty much
mummy's been like a lord dude has been a
kingdom [ __ ] deliverance Simon not
getting into that thought I was making a
dent and come to find out I'm really
still early in the game a tower tutorial
that I thought that I was doing
something together Couture's
I think I've been playing for eight
hours
thought I was doing something get my
list and check that [ __ ] off language
then literally I get to a point it's
like the credits come up like an intro
to a movie and I'm like what
so yeah the Soul Stealer there's no
doubt about it I want to go I've been
doing he actually got back in the world
blade I was stucked at a couple of
points
cousin playing solo obviously and I'm
actually be the boss that I was give me
a lot of trouble so I'm trying to get
that done and I shall come more sinister
on he he harassed me for weeks and weeks
and telling me now about this fortnight
update he knows I'm a pub G guy but we
did play fortnight
60 frames per second on the X Wow it
looks fantastic
I can't even from I'm not a foreign I
got I am more pop jjigae but I cannot
front on that update to what they're
doing to that engine it looks
spectacular so we did that and we also
did sea of deep stress test shot the
Lord Valley con we had a decrees in
there and lets out the big bad John we
had a little little captain people were
threatening each other who's the captain
now and no threatening there was
sinister thought he was the cat from but
he was well you decided to take the boat
on a voyage without your crew that's
what the problem started then so did
somewhat damaged the boat we didn't know
where the water was leaking in so he's
funky but I was we got our you know a
little issues out the way we did find
the treasures on the map and stuff that
we were we had a little fun we're gonna
get into the show we had a lip roll last
week the results of him that people have
spoken to the question with the
successful release of remakes and
remasters like shadow of colossus and
last of us to should these type of
titles warrant a review the winner at
39% and our closest and most competitive
three-way ILP poll what's the null only
discussed the enhancements of the
remakes and remasters group coming in at
a razor close second per second place
that 35% was the yes review the remakes
and remasters the second time based on
their merit and coming in that third
place at 26% was the i don't care
they're all cash grabs anyway do what do
you think about this whole weary
reviewing of remasters you know i love
the idea of remasters okay I love the
idea it allows people who might have
missed it to play it in an updated form
obviously it's a different game than
what originally came out its remastered
so it's much different iam so I do think
those deserve reviews but I don't think
it deserves to replace the previous
review
on a concept of like what's new not
review in the game as a whole again
that's alright yeah like okay this
stupid Tora thing is coming out like
it's I picked it up on Steam I picked it
up on Steam when it came out to see what
it was right and it's essentially like
it's it's just a pretty tough n64
version of the game like dual analog
controls like yeah we haven't installed
it for that sure but it's not I mean the
game itself is the same should be a four
dollar game I mean cuz you know what it
is like you have real good people labels
the love people really do labels the
love and I'm not saying you know that
that wasn't hot worked on hard or
whatever I don't care really be honest
with you and maybe you're like sovereign
said you know the nostalgia part they
reaching for their crowd all right well
you know what get back to that crowd to
drop the price down to four dollars what
would be the equivalent oh you know what
is the word or join game pass and throw
it in there for free because I would
tell you something I saw the game I saw
people raging talking about oh my god
two rockets coming out oh I gotta see
this I gotta see
okay this is a comparison video they're
gonna show you is just a comparison for
the old graphics but they can tell you
about the developers like Rockstar have
gave us a game for the exact same price
they did it two years ago and put
first-person mode in it what gets worth
it
yes average oh my god we got a new poker
at the end of the show we got a lot of
times we go channel powered through we
got some stuff going on right now we're
setting off hot off the presses
speculation and rumors going on and it
just puts my attention actually shoutout
to MBG does he put a video up first he's
one of the first on this and I want to
get him on the show I know he doesn't do
podcast often but um yeah man he was the
first to kind of actually comment on one
of these things as well as actually on
correctly correctly from I can say it's
a that Jess just Gordon from Windows
Central and um we saw this as well and
then there was some cryptic tweets going
on I'm gonna share this on the screen
let me know if you guys can see if the
lords can see this okay so we saw this
on the sega official site you know I
have my Google Japanese translator I was
talking to Lord do it I was like what is
going on here you scroll down and then
you just see Sega Japan gorgeous Seattle
office
this is the real Microsoft Office she's
going on you see in Sonic's next two
Xbox ones and cozy Microsoft Office like
a what is going on now we do know that
obviously you know Microsoft had the
ability to purchase them in the past
that never felt it did fell through with
Sega but um we and we also heard rumors
just recently right that um you know
that they've been that Marx was trying
to make some big acquisitions or some
big partnerships but I also want to give
credit where credit is due and I want to
shout out odd cap because Lord cow from
tech podcast our guy you know say last
Sunday planets like he was the first he
put this up last year and basically he
got like a press release
you know from Sega about stepping down
the co-ceo oh and Europe and the
partnership that they were they were
going and work on and look who was on
the list that this was May of 2017 you
know and I just want to bring this to
the Lord again this
is all speculation right we don't have
any clues as to what's going on but when
we see images like this it leads me to
believe you know okay what's going on
here so um what do do we think something
is possibly between Microsoft and Sega
what do you think man I I mean I want to
believe that this is just you know if
Sega's out on a trip to Seattle to see
what's going on but there's just too
much in these pictures there's a lot of
stuff like if you scroll down to the one
you got Sonic's standing next to next to
an Xbox
that's just like really and then if you
scroll down to the next two photos the
one on the right yes that when you begin
and if you zoom in on that
yeah the reflection on the 360 you can
see Sonic is sitting on something there
like that it's like they wanted to just
make sure they could get Sonic in the
background see it's right there Sonic
somebody's playing a game and there's
Sonic so I want to see it be coop that's
something cryptic but I guess we'll have
to wait and see but and this is just
very strange see these pictures just pop
up and there's not a whole lot of
details to like the captions to these
ones and what's on the screen what do
they play in there I don't know I think
a little Sonic mania and stuff like okay
you know kinda thing I think was
mentioned it is just very cryptic
messaging going on lost so we say good
kids man I'm going back to your point
about how they had the opportunity to
purchase them years ago on it didn't
happen I mean they I mean there was
talks about Xbox being compatible with
Dreamcast too and whatever that was
gonna be like they would there's been a
love affair between Sega and Microsoft
to a certain extent for years so it's
conness t I don't know what to expect
from this because the thing is when we
talked about you know potential
purchases for them a while back Sega
never came up and say good I mean again
part of Xbox is DNA comes from the
fallout of Sega and the Dreamcast like
that's that's where the that's where
they came from so before the whole
Kinect
with them as well to remember exactly
exactly so a former head of Sega I'm
going over to Xbox so it's me you know
who knows if there's something in the
work from the Perth to Sega at the same
time like you know sonic they did one IP
that's really really hitting it out of
the park that what in one aspect was
sonic mania last year which sonic mania
did well all across the board
besides that like you know generations
or whatever the one that came out
afterwards didn't do so well it went
back to that crappy formula 3d formula
that people have not been happy with um
and then also like all the bayonetta
love on nintendo now i don't really know
what to think about that so it could be
it could be some mighty cloud but it is
say listen it's a Sega property so I
don't know you know I don't really know
what to think about it it could be some
it could be some IP it could be one IP
in particular who knows but I mean no
one Microsoft I mean and they're talking
big the thing is if it comes to
something like that listen they started
negotiations I guarantee the B'nai the
Bayonetta 3 and stuff was way before
this negotiation right so I mean again
it could be the date they looking to buy
the whole thing is gonna be interesting
a minute all the pictures are very
cryptic you have no idea what it
actually means and it could be very
little small or could be huge so
something concrete some more data Claude
King I need y'all in on this which was
you know he put in a hell of a lot of
where I'll actually watch his streams on
the low
you
don't know him and I saw him picture
this ol Sega Microsoft cryptic Warner's
pictures I mean if they were to get Sega
what's the number one thing do you think
they would pick up with say uh mm-hmm
you know that number one thing I want
you guys are referring to you know
people are excited about Sonic ones last
cuz sonic we had verge the great day but
they do own that could be in-house now
the possibility if there was this big
partnership going on that's a lot of our
piece that can be reimagined also we do
know obviously the Shenmue thing I don't
know how that place you know Panzer drag
there's a ton of IPs that Sega had that
has been kind of will say dormant they
just always been doing anything with
right so it just to me again this is all
speculation this is if these rumors if
there's any truth to them it would
embolden and just give Microsoft are
great in-house for quality kind of
lineup if that is the case you know I
mean so and stay tuned for the polity
and Ashoka's we're gonna touch on this
again but um I'm I'm excited I mean we
did hear rumors of this stuff before you
know I definitely want to shout out cow
because you know he put this out there
you know that Microsoft was on the
partnership list
there is some truth to what may be
happening behind the scenes and if that
is nice
that is tremendous I think that's a
great because that's the prodigal
annoyed you like everyone complains that
Microsoft does not have the first party
that Sony has right and they don't have
these you know in-house things they
always have to kind of buy like a pub G
and stuff like that
and if you get these game these four
franchises that are beloved you know I
mean could you imagine a fantasy storm
like I'll get Dreamcast gar like people
are going crazier just the thought of
this stuff on Twitter but I'm gonna
bring my lord King what did you feel
when you saw all this stuff no job
before exactly what the whole dynamic
between Sega and Microsoft was I told
you Microsoft is the baby we never
wanted bacon was the child that was
stillborn
that we want it and died so Microsoft
just inherited baby
no no Microsoft is a strong baby the
baby that she was like oh wow that
little runt look at that thing is gonna
make it and they're pushing the pushing
and pushing the push the only way for
Microsoft to really India itself to that
crowd that crowd that keeps wishing for
Sega is to eat it I'm quiet Sega
I love you crazy taxi and he doesn't
know they're irrelevant and Sega's hands
so in Microsoft fans where's cash flush
situation and they need this okay
just gonna go into your topic all right
and the topic that you have coming up
later as far as Microsoft and the
streaming stuff in the game pass that's
putting people on
there's putting people like these do
they know people know they're talking
them they trying to make huge
acquisitions to push this game past
things so far into your face that if you
have a xbox live subscription you damn
sure got a game pass description they're
trying to have that one-on-one parody
with it so that if you got 30 million
Xbox one live subscriptions and you got
30 million gamepad subscriptions
Microsoft is trying to fatten the
wallets it's gonna happen
we need the games everybody keeps
talking about where's the games they're
gonna get the games and if you buy a
Sega
although Sega fans mmm very interesting
again like I said we're oh it's all
speculation is nothing final but you
know like me nor dude said it's just
kind of interesting the nature of
cryptic tweets and we've seen companies
do kind of stuff like this in the past
when they want to kind of preview an
announcement in it's cool they actually
like the fact that it's actually saying
of Japan you know because that was also
you know another criticism of Microsoft
they can't get you know the Japanese
someone did not say the next Crazy Taxi
yeah like it just you know like I said
that's always been like the Achilles
heel that they can't do anything in
Japan you can't lose a clutch and you
know crack open it I think that's cool
what's the question money in Sega games
come in to this next generation of
gaming and still be successful like they
were 10-15 years ago that's a poll
question that's a poll question that's a
poll question we will not have the idea
for this stuff a two-part poll question
because I got it I got a good with to we
get right now a they bought them all
that's no I don't know what happened but
I think
cradles the fear is real yeah literally
the opposite so we go on I'm gonna pass
it to my brother from another mother
Lord addict
we are both huge state of decay fans
what is going on well apparently the
game has been priced for $25 in UK so I
think the release dates about to get
announced in UK uh they they they messed
up and put the price before the date so
there's a good chance it's gonna be 25
all wide so what do you guys think about
that you think that uh now since we from
60 to 25 we expect a $25 game and out of
60 oh man you know this is this is
really strange that you guys mentioned
before there's no no talk about this
from Microsoft and maybe maybe some of
these uh these retailers in the UK have
jumped the gun here but you know in the
u.s. currently all the retailers show
$59.99 and this is supposed to be a big
sequel to us and it became the first one
so this is a full-on game and for having
to have it listed a 25-pound okay right
now I gotta interrupt you it is I forgot
the currency exchange
okay guys excuse me will correct us like
no correct this is what it is see I love
it yes thank you so much but now you hit
so basically it's like around forty
forty dollars may seem like thirty nine
enough so that you'll or do like does
what do you have concerns about that
like where you at with that
well you know I played the first
straight in state of decay I told you I
picked it up when it came out to Xbox
one cuz I him like hey zombies I'll play
this I'll give it a try and it's it's
just something I didn't get into because
you know the lack of co-op you know
that's something I really wanted to play
in that game but uh and at the same time
I didn't think it ate very well I didn't
think it looked very good on the ax
compare the Xbox one compared to some of
the other games I had already played and
the man the management system wasn't
quite didn't resonate well with me so I
ended up taking it back but to see if
there's a price drop this puts it in
line at $40 u.s. that's sort of similar
what we saw three core recore was I
thought record was a decent game up
until about midway when it kind of lost
its way but it's been you know they've
done what they've had to do to repair it
into and to get it to you know make a
little bit more sense after the halfway
point but to see this if this launch is
at $40 I mean I don't see there's any
I'm not gonna I'm not going to assume
the worst I mean this is a big title
they've been promoting this but you know
III never we never want to see a game
fail but and we should never ever look
at a price as an indication of a game in
trouble people could say what they want
look if it's 40 your expectations had to
be $40 price tag not it so you can't
compare a $40 game to a 60 you can
compare a $20 game to a 60 like you do
at there's some kind of adjustments that
can I jump in for devil's advocate
purpose um here's the thing Lord ooh
you're right
I mean you can't look at something and
loadout if you're right as one like you
can't look at something face value just
say oh because it's this it's ultimately
you know gonna reflect badly on the
quality game right glass all so I'm
gonna let you jump do you know where I'm
going with this the optics of it don't
look good
they've been touting this game state of
decay one was was something of a small
miracle on the 360 it had a huge
following but still kind of under the
radar since they announced it of decay
to the talk around it has been this is a
full-fledged triple-a title we are
taking the concept of state of decay to
and blowing it out giving you all
co-op multiplayer I think four-player
multiplayer so it's it's a it's a much
bigger undertaking than the first
so by a $40 price point coming out
before the game is even the release date
of the game has even been announced we
haven't really we haven't seen any live
gameplay of it like I think some people
saw her stuff behind the scene yeah
behind the scenes at e3 so we we don't
we still really don't know what the game
is in someone's hands how it feels so it
yeah it's a little bit concerning that
again and there's a lot of other things
think about when it comes to this with
the whole look at it being Europe so far
we're not seeing anything from from the
from the US and a bit like Europe as you
know as we saw with the with the whole
backlash on game past with some of the
some of the the stores over there
feeling that well you know we don't Xbox
doesn't do well over here as it is why
should we support this when you're
taking money out of our hands so Ronnie
you can also be seen as a backlash from
from UK retailers saying you know what
we dropping the price of this so takes
off and you steal a quick me a new dish
is been like I said acting King and then
it's meeting you on the same wavelength
we've been Lords have been on two
opposite at wavelengths this year but
yeah like yeah I get finishing I'll jump
in I just think if we don't see anything
respond in kind on the US side of it
when is something to be worried about on
the retailer side like it's it's them
feeling like they're attacking the bully
you know
so we'll see what it is I mean you know
I'm kind of the same mindset you know
I'm not gonna go crazy is just like you
said from an optics perspective I was it
was presented as if like let's be honest
a to decay one was like this
Indian labor of love kind of game right
was like a hard core you know no one
expected much of it you know we jumped
on and we like wow tremendous depth you
know it's way bigger than just a simple
game you know and it's a you knows a lot
of complexities to it so then when they
announced part two they announced the
four player co-op they announced the
scope bigger better yada yada yada you
don't it to mind picking was
like marketed as this triple-a
big-budget kind of a deal like we were
going all-in you know we're putting you
know the Microsoft's backing behind it
so when I see the $40 or you know
equivalent in UK price drop my eyebrows
raised slightly only from the standpoint
of value proposition right because my
thing is if if you feel that this is
packed in with a ton of content like why
do you say to yourself okay we're gonna
bring the price down right if you're
confident in what's in the content then
you in my opinion it's like okay Dan you
should stick behind the 60 now the only
other thing I was thinking about just
you know just to say okay well what else
could it be what possibly else could it
be
the only thing else I was thinking about
was like won't like what loss off kind
of hinted to which is you know maybe
because this is the UK only so far right
you know maybe this is their way of
retaliating against game pass and we
know that you know state of decay too is
a game pass game right we know that um
you know there was an issue backlash I
guess it was just one Austrian retailer
but you know let's be honest you know
there's a lot of retailers that are
concerned with Microsoft's digital push
into this new era you're not I'm saying
so maybe this is their way of saying
fold for the first party titles you
gotta let us drop this bad boy down
since you've given this thing away in
game just all this is speculation I'm
literally just speculating that kind of
thing but um I just thought it was
interesting I was just a little
concerned I mean I I love static knows
like we are state of decay guys you know
I'm saying and again I just want to see
more on it I just hope that there's no
lesser content
I hope there's you know that everything
is on schedule and ready to see well
that's what I got on it but the Lord
Lord King what do you what do you make
of all it is not this news is coming out
good news halo 5 is coming out there
used to be $59.99
$25.99 oh man what's going on with Halo
I'm getting it for free overhearing game
pass right so maybe Microsoft say yo for
those girls that don't got game pass
we're gonna drop that down to this price
right here so you can get the equivalent
but yo if you really want to get it for
that low jump over here for game pass
let's work it out here's a good now on
all their games are gonna be clear
that's what I said I said the only thing
I could come up with is this is the
retailer you know retaliatory
let's say Microsoft said 42 yes right
it's crazy you know so let's say
Microsoft themselves say you know what
um for us to compete we have to show
value we have to show our commitment and
this is part of that whole value
commitment thing like you know our prime
games our top choice games you don't
have to remember what I said they stay
they announce the date for um God of War
yeah it was like April 20th so what we
know is coming out all kids get even say
anything special like a price drop
you didn't say $49.99 god of war
wouldn't would you feel devalued if they
said God of War was 29 $5.99 you play
well let me go pre-order because they
think Stata decays in a $60 game maybe
this is their call that this is their
answer to competing with third-party
titles yes the thing is with Microsoft
is that the perception with Microsoft
being in second place right is that they
have to do things to appeal more to the
consumer like if Sony dropped the price
on on God of War is because they feel
like it now because they so the
perception is different like the
perception is different you wouldn't
think it's God of War is imprison
trouble low Microsoft the position
they're in
you know yelling is like okay what else
can you give me to make me come over to
you and in combination with the fact
that and again shout to mbg he's got a
great video out right now I was going
back and forth with him this morning is
the perception also let's be honest we
have not heard a peep now a state of
decay so there's some nervousness I mean
from a Microsoft standpoint right let's
be honest right we went through the
scalebound drama right we saw we were we
had our noses in the air like you don't
say and you know at certain events
behind closed doors and we were like
right me and act like why they keep
showing us this trailer
where's game how come there's no kiosk
what's going on right so again you from
a Microsoft standpoint we have to be
concerned a little bit that they were so
tight-lipped about it so we just want to
make sure that everything's okay you
want to make sure the baby's being born
there's no just go out and lock in that
price if that price sounds good to you
it could be a flow price now did you
feel good are you trying to pinch a
dollar that is that if the game comes
out in its middle ink or mediocre all
the narrative around it is gonna focus
on that price and what he dropped that
price exactly sovereign you know why I
really don't
give to UPS about this part right here I
used to play all right so my level of
tolerance for games only different than
this new crowd US retail is still saying
60 which is true also pay for it in the
u.s. a lot of people are also making a
good point I want to shout out abacab I
want to shout out fast back there making
good points like did we feel the same
way when hell-blade was $40 was there
any smoke up in the air for that
hopefully I didn't have a prequel though
that is true considered stated okay with
only 20 euro cradles to the Chango he
said cuz the PlayStation games are $80
worthy of ducks
yeah but hell-blade was always talked
about as a game that was being made on a
small budget and it was almost more like
the way they talked about that game
wasn't that it was supposed to be a
triple-a extravaganza type game so to be
honest with you what if they ever made
you think that this is their big triple
again that's what I'm trying to say talk
about it when they talked about what
they were doing even the head of undead
labs has said it like he said this is
this is not what you think it is so if
you had a hot turret the first time
right move the stink off the turn it's
vastly improved when they made escapist
and they said well we're gonna have
character development we're gonna have
twice as many escapable prisons does
that mean it's a trial you can't just
because they have better thought press
as to what they want to do at the game
it does it automatically makes it a
triple-a title but it's faint but it's
fair if the guy in charge is saying it
like it's a guy if I'm making it up on
my own accord I think this is bigger and
better
you know person to say we're doing the
exact same
but guys like like Louis all fear where
the optics are like optics are like
kidding it like it's a triple-a like its
own like when you see the market it's on
the same level as the crackdowns and
it's not in the corner like it's like a
marketing CDs and it's a forty dollar
title yeah and and and another thing too
is that again like we just we we ready
ready we just want to learn more about
it and like I said on debt is just
putting a little tight lip so just it's
interesting imma let the dude close out
the tap before we move on
should we are we over worrying are we
panicking too much lore dude two things
I want to mention to you guys I'm gonna
get your thoughts on the second one
specifically but the first one is you
know Fastback mentioned how blade I
think this gen it's a lot different when
you see these quote-unquote budget
titles last gen when you got a budget
title some of those games you were like
man this this thing's still overpriced
but now this jack even before hell blade
I would argue that Sniper Elite 3 when
that came out and I think it was late
2014 early 2015
that game was a budget title but man I
thought that game was awesome it had a
big campaign I had co-op I had
multiplayer and I thought it was a well
done game so I think they've kind of
gotten past the whole cheap price means
cheap game you know especially with how
blade that game was fantastic but now
the other thing I want to go back to
just really quick you guys were
mentioned about maybe who's responsible
for the price raft in the UK is at
retailers or is it Microsoft would you
guys say that game pass is something
that Microsoft is really really pushing
like they really want their user base to
get ugly so absolutely that would tell
me why would Microsoft lower the price
of retail games that they're trying to
get people to go to game pass I'm gonna
say that's more retailer if that is the
case if this is something that's really
happening I'm gonna go more retailer
because it'd be contradicting Microsoft
if there was a Hey look we want to push
game pass but hey let's knock down the
retail versions what let me ask you this
a little or do what if he's what if the
retailers are on the UK side Europeans
are are giving push back
what are they cuz remember we did see
that no was one Austrian retailer he
removed all Xbox games first you know he
was like you guys are not kidding to us
now granted he was like a mom and pops
he wasn't like game over they
you know he was the crazy sounds his 5
seconds is up you did sob I'll bet you
he's still selling Microsoft stuff now
decay on Reed oil free like yo work I
get that you go to a room that's green
what if what if this is the what if this
is the I won't be surprised if it was
push back because like I said we've seen
the hype that this game past
announcement has generated I mean
there's a lot of Excel i'm getting game
pass I mean I heard of I was like oh
yeah this is this is a no-brainer you
know but and so you look at these
retailers they're give me I came in this
is gonna cut into our our our sales be
surprised whatsoever if this is just the
start of it i'ma move through the game
pass and one CEO thieves comes out and
that thing starts sound crazy game past
so it goes up retail sales go down I
won't be surprised off you see retailers
start making more moves over here in the
u.s. it might not be on the sites right
now but then again you guys this could
like you guys mentioned somebody hit the
wrong button over I mean to the second
point dude second point about whether
it's push back or not I remember I think
is Matt piscatella who said something
about how its shown that game pass up on
to this point has generated more
has generated more sales for individual
games on their own whether they be a
launch or whether they be you know a
year after launch because people having
access to the game whether they stick to
the up to the service or not once they
have access to it for a little while if
they like the game and the price point
is right on for buying the game you know
digitally or whatever in the store
they'll just go out numbers have shown
that they'll go out and purchase the
game regardless so so it could be like
again it could it could be pushed back
from these retailers to say you know
what now we're gonna win a beat you to
the punch and and drop the price in your
game and you deal with the fallout of
the bat or here's the thing lost a lot
loss off some loss Sam again he's saying
if it's reach this is retailer pushback
he said to pare dummies that they're
getting a small right now and sell the
games and ask them and I think because
it Microsoft's not gonna take less
because they want to sell it for less
they're gonna break more their initial
budget and they're gonna have to take
less than they don't really would get
sick of what they're earning on the game
is gonna be less yeah whatever they okay
Microsoft for the game is whatever it is
right yeah I'm I saw a P difference down
to Microsoft right I would see any of
them doing that mmm nope this is
interesting we got it we got a bona to
this one this is this is something we
got to keep tabs this is Australian dude
cuz he's not so you know it's a monthly
thing but I like this
this time I'm double dipping right I'm
gonna give you a little bit of MPD
numbers nothing too crazy with MPD
numbers no somebody lost they switch
yeah
after the NPD numbers I'm getting into
Phil Spencer's die speech so let's start
with MPD so on the hardware for Nintendo
switch so the most consoles where with
Sony coming in switch early so we just
that's pretty self-explanatory came in
second in making overall most revenue so
they made the most money but so the most
amount of consoles and Xbox one came in
third
so just the most interesting little
tidbit with these figures is that and
shout out to Matt piscatella for this
tidbit of information the difference in
revenue between switch and an Xbox or
first place and third place it's only
about 3% so they're all doing selling
all selling great yeah Oh something
great but there's too many more people
on the subway people on the switch
[Applause]
[Applause]
is that robbery that was actually look
at is uh is one of them sophomore say
listen listen listen
drop dead game the same time another
triple a title drops whatever the hell
her name is
you're blaming Capcom because they were
smart oh you know you know listen listen
you're in normal position on it my
position is okay yeah it's a good game
of the dead month
hey now drop that same game against a
game when it testicles that put the
testicles on the table baby
over there you and Jesse Jackson this is
a podcast for everyone and then in the
beginning when I said my blood is green
look at the DNA Xbox it's green keep it
funky everything that's vomit green I
got a whole bunch of it in me no Kratos
Kratos is my man
we're gonna get girls to the show I love
is God Kratos add me on PlayStation is
xbox360 level world was number one on
both PlayStation and Xbox and it is
heartening for me to see that Xbox crowd
gravitating to the game because you know
fanboy talk is like it's not gonna do
numbers on Xbox and it did so I'm happy
about that it's good to see that um on
the switch Super Mario Odyssey Mario
Kart 8 is of the birth of breath the
wild with one two and three doing well
um year-over-year accessories doing
gangbusters like accessories like when
you talk about these controllers like
the color joy Khan's kiss moves about
the homie one here in a couple minutes
yeah shall turtle beach turtle beach was
up there to get those rigs get those
most loved career so they say they
should be seeing a surgeon and no stairs
at at some point as well so I mean
overall like year-over-year those
increases in hardware software accessory
sales revenue like so overall the
business of gaming is in a great place a
fantastic I love that so that so now I
was saying hip hop was dead not long ago
no doubt before you jump in from if I
just want to comment on the MV to eat um
what I wasn't to I don't want to
understate is well pub G going from
number seven last month to number four
and as the not like that tremendous and
that doesn't include PC sales you just I
got excited
I actually laugh as smiling what happens
I'm like you guys are a great us has a
feel to us being number two when it
comes to pubsey oh you're not even on
the board one more thing - if I can
dear-dear to all of our hearts where the
hell is destiny - on this lists not even
old top do Dragon Ball xenoverse one out
soul destiny - yeah it's weird that was
weird but it came back like one mixtape
away let's keep it real if you look at
if you look at the individual systems
not even in the top ten on the
PlayStation 4 or Xbox ones yeah and and
and to put things into perspective one
when destiny one came out you know that
had an identity crisis of his own right
anywhere in 2015 that was ranked number
nine no you're absolutely right I mean
the only thing great was saving grace is
that it had such a tremendous start and
that is like number three of the
best-selling games over the past twelve
months for the year because of how
tremendous star but like you said it's
been completely fading off the list and
it just goes to show what the state of
the game is but great great point or do
Lord are soft let's get into our fill
and about to get into that so yeah like
I said like the overall business of
gaming is doing great so that brings me
to my second the second part of my topic
which sort of addresses an aspect of
gaming which isn't necessarily in as
good of a place um and that's the
culture of gaming and when I talk about
the culture of gaming I'm talking about
you know toxicity in the fan community
and sort of ingrained but biases and
toxic corporate culture in the
development end of the gaming community
right so in his opening keynote address
at this year's Die summit Phil Spencer
addresses these problems like within the
industry he talks about how they
affected Microsoft as a whole and he
talks about how it affected the Xbox
division in particular hmm so in his
talk he talks about the difficulties he
had in
sort of turning the Xbox brand around
mm-hmm and how that required a sort of
you know fundamental revaluation of what
their corporate structure is and and the
the evaluation you know had to be made
for a few reasons I am one and he had to
sort of reinvigorate the Xbox team and
have them believe in what the new vision
for Xbox was you know they kind of
flubbed the the launch of the Xbox one
and they needed people to believe in in
management's vision once again and then
second to that or in addition to that is
they had to work towards eradicating
what's seen as you know the systematic
harassment and biases both like you know
call Patrol and sexual which the present
in the corporate culture of the
development community and that's that's
a topic that again it's things that have
been happening recently in the world
have sort of brought all this stuff up
to light and so um so he spoke about the
difficulty and sort of acknowledging his
own faults right and prejudices in in
order to be able to get everyone to
believe in and subscribe to the change
that they were trying to to work towards
right and the change which includes you
know it's about inclusivity it's about
safety and it's about diversity in the
world work environment right he made it
clear that it's imperative that the
development community self police
themselves like and take the initiative
to improve their culture because like
only then can they a do their best work
and the true potential of what gaming
can become can be realized that you have
to look at yourself in the mirror and
and see what you're doing wrong in order
to improve he also talked about leading
by example and how that would sort of
translate the corporate culture to sort
of ultimately improve the fan culture
around gaming and and its online
communities obviously there's a lot of
toxicity in the online communities and
thankfully we don't subscribe to that
stuff I think we're where we sort of
show the opposite end of that spectrum
but it's it's good that they understand
that the example that they set on their
end filters
to how we how we do things on our end as
fans of these of these communities right
so at the end of the day like you would
hope that this talk inspires the entire
gaming community to sort of be better
right
and the thing about it is even if you're
tone deaf to all this stuff and you
don't care about it and it doesn't
matter to you he indicates that the
bottom line is that like he indicated
that you know it's who's everyone to
create a work environment where everyone
feels safe appreciated and respected and
it makes as much common sense as it does
business sense is it that word so though
at the end of the day you know cog and I
we always get Phil flack for kind of his
perceived lack of aggressiveness right
yeah especially in the face of like
sometimes when he gets like overtly or
Microsoft or Xbox cast covertly attacked
by its competitors he doesn't respond in
kind right but to be honest I think that
he is the perfect ambassador for this
message in particular right he's a Mike
you know he's a Microsoft lifer who's
seen and he's experienced everything on
both sides of gaming cult-like he's not
yet he's not your typical soup you know
what I mean like I feel he he's a gamer
who happens to be in a position of power
in gaming and I think it it lends the
message even more credence right right
and the thing about the message is that
it serves kind of about a call to arms
to I say call to arms because then
shout-out to Lord Brack for this cuz he
he tweeted about this and then he um I
think he had a rant about it but you
know once again gaming a popular culture
under attack my pockets pockets of the
political establishment absolutely yeah
you know and although the merits of you
know the digital violence be getting
actual violence argument those murders
are questionable right but the matter
there are other aspects of gaming
culture that at this point are are
tangibly more attackable and you know
and trust me when I say like none of us
want the government regulating any
aspect of the entertainment that we
consume especially more content
perspective right like you know with the
elimination of net neutrality like
they're already affecting how we're
gonna be accessing this content so you
know we don't want them in any way shape
involved in and anything having to do
with gaming so at the end of the day his
speech should serve as like an important
wake-up call to everybody in the gaming
community that we a need to be visually
we need to be open minded and at the end
of the day we need to clean up our own
house and worry about us for the good of
gaming today and ultimately what we want
gaming to be in the future you know I
mean so I think it's a very important
speech from the ideal person to give it
absolutely now I do we got a little
cradle saying as well as our Lord dude I
just want to ask one did you guys get a
chance to listen to the Phil Spencer
speech and if you did any thoughts and
comments on it so let's start with a
little cradle that you just jumped in
real quick yeah my first Masters
likability to me shot through the roof
when he did that he's put some real
things sometimes it's okay to put gaming
aside and focus on the bigger picture
because he's a bigger picture guy right
he has a new role he can't be stuck on
the small things and I spoke on
diversity in gaming cue the toxics
toxicity and stuff like that it's much
larger right than just some guys on you
to the Twitter bickering over some NPD
numbers you got people that have real
influence guys they have millions and
millions of followers and stuff like
that I'll take the the whole pooty-poo
incident and you take the other guy
those are bigger issues right because
they have larger follow larger fathers
so their word means a lot more to a lot
of followers and so you know shout out
to feel Spencer for there I'm glad that
he was able to tackle that and speak on
it and kind of show with Microsoft plan
to do on tackling some of these issues
on diversity
you know women and all of sudden it's
all great for gaming right I think 17
was the year of call of the year the
female because we had you know you know
gravity rush it was just so many games
that ended up being great and it showed
that it doesn't always have to be one
particular guy or character that
displays so I you know Charlotte to feel
special for that I think you know his
likability in my particular arena we
wait absolutely Lord dude did you get a
chance to catch the Phil Spencer speech
at dice I did and I thought it was
fantastic and Lord sovereign and Kratos
made some great points they've addressed
quite a few the issues that I that I I
liked about it the one part that really
stood out to me though was his talk
about the inclusivity yes essentially
amongst his team and other developers
you know I like how he mentioned there
allowed developers from all walks of
life I mean these teams are made up of
people with all sorts of backgrounds
regardless of their orientation their
gender the color of their skin I mean
all all these different people back
walks of life that that create these
studios and I like how he pointed out
look we need to hear from everybody we
want equal input on how games are made
and the stories they tell you know what
I'm saying like you get their input as
well because when you look at the game
like hell blade it puts you into the
shoes of not just a woman that which is
awesome but also a person dealing with
mental issues
that gives you a full understanding a
better understanding of their
perspective of what life is like through
their eyes and I think by going to these
other developers or the other members of
the team and giving them equal voice and
how they create these games this will
translate well to gamers because it'll
give us what it will hopefully build
empathy and compassion for other people
that we can't quite relate to one-to-one
you know mm-hmm absolutely I mean yeah I
mean it was one of those moments that I
mean I know Lord King knows I mean I've
been very hard on Phil from I'm just
talking my from the you know his
position standpoint it's far and not the
person the man I always meant him a
couple times great guy right so my whole
thing was like you notice a bottom-line
business whatever whatever he's gotta
get aggressive I'm coming from that like
a Peter Moore era with my xbox 360 you
know Microsoft was very aggressive that
kind of thing so I've been extra hard on
him but I've always told King this cuz I
know that's Kings guys his excellent son
[Music]
and my thing was just like okay you know
not he's in position and and let's be
honest and in defense to him he he got
served a very bad plate with the Xbox
when he start and what I thought was
impressive he actually mentioned that
how the morale was low mm-hmm you know
those meetings he had to get the trust
back the stuff like that so from the
games perspective perspective I really
appreciated his transparency but then
when he got into social issues what's
going on in the community what's going
on with gamers it resonated with me so
much like I'm like damn I got so much
respect for him as a man because he's
tackling the issues that are actually
I'm talking exactly he was talking about
what's going on with Black Panther he
into social consciousness and he made a
line he was just like now the pixel is
greater than the pen and now that's
another thing that kind of resonated
with me because gaming does hold that
you know authority and stuff like that I
just like everything in the messaging
everything as far as inclusion and
diversity women in gaming you know mine
or it was very powerful and I didn't
expect that it took me a while to watch
I know I'm like how about some more
solver telling me like hey a lot of
watch that feels principes you got away
you know it was powerful yeah he fired
and yeah kudos to Phil you know I'm
curious to see where his journey and it
goes and you know from the Xbox
perspective he keeps this up your man
Lord King you might be up imma beat a
morgue I gotta be on but Phil man kudos
to you salute speech with X and looking
I know you want to jump in I got a
piggyback off of what Kratos was saying
um the 2017 was the year of the female
and not in the sense that when I say the
year the female the powerful female okay
because you have to look at it in zero
horizons going I probably say the name
wrong all the time but I have the game
alright she's fully clothed from head to
toe okay so get that part right so
there's no putting it in a sexual
overtone that you want to see this
avatar isn't that's not there it's just
gay married you understand so now that
we're looking at it from game merit and
you have little girls wanting to be
these girls these powerful females in
video games that's fantastic now as far
as what he was talking about is as the
culture um that's addressing all the
stuff that we're hearing about inside
these game development studios of
harassment and things of that nature and
biasness towards a skin color and
religion that's going on behind these
closed doors and when he's telling
everybody is to take a big view of
yourself and internalize that and treat
others how you want to be treated to
bring that out in their environment
right and I think if you start with me
first mentality that I'm gonna do this
first I'm gonna hold the door for this
person I'm gonna hold the elevator for
this person coming in I'm gonna say good
morning trust me when you don't know
what anyone's dealing with day to day so
when you extend the hand of somebody you
might be
sending extra one up to that person you
understand he needed that to get going
so I've always liked his message his
message has never been us versus them
yeah he's been in clever than that from
you know we joke with the fanboys that
look right joke but it's like even from
he was one of the first executives to
kind of mention the other platforms Wow
discussions I remember you know a lot of
people in they like that also always be
red pill versus blue pill right it's all
this is what we're taught right it's
always supposed to be Democrat versus
Republican it's always supposed to be
blue versus red it's always supposed to
be us versus them saying that they don't
believe that y'all are different
entities understand we're gamers period
ok so I don't care where you game at
you're doing the same exact thing that
I'm doing you are gaming it is it
doesn't make any sense for the fanboy
ISM I I have a Playstation so if I
really hated it I wouldn't give them a
nickel alright and I'm pretty sure that
I purchased more PlayStation a lot of
people that you know um but again fill
speech was important to the point that
this we have to change internally to
hourly effect everything alright and
when we start making video games that
shows that we internalize these things
like Detroit Detroit has a couple of
topics that I really want to see and our
medium because I believe our medium is
going to reach more people than the
actual cinemas now
with your net load king I know I know I
got I don't you try got uh you know last
back what's going on I want those
subject matters tackled not want
government to be involved in censoring
us and I'm tired of every time someone
does something they blame video games as
the catalyst to push you to that point
yeah where where the easy scapegoat
because they're gonna point to call to
duty but Call of Duty doesn't make up
90% of our community you understand
there are other games in our community
are that is thought-provoking that is
empathetic to other people that is
loving heartwarming stories that bring
you to tears that has absolutely nothing
to do with bloodshed mm-hmm so don't use
those platforms to demonize our medium
because our medium is not based on one
genre absolutely they're just my point
and what I got from his speech and I
knew it was gonna be powerful because
like I said I put all my chips in one
basket anything else on your tablet
before we move on the conversation
around this stuff is great and like I
said I think he's the perfect ambassador
to deliver this message I think he's
respected throughout the gaming industry
both by fans and by by professionals in
the industry so I think it goes a long
way for him to deliver that message and
to give his personal story as to what
Microsoft is going through right now
what Xbox is going through right now it
matters it matters on every front and I
think we need to really pay attention to
that and like I said like we're being
attacked once again you know I thought
you know hot coffee and remember when
the heck is that name or what the back
Thompson I thought all that was behind
us and it's not and it's not it's on us
as a community of fans and developers to
put you know police our own house and
make sure that it's tight I said good
good good points and Sheldon Lopez I
know me Hemingway's landlord Brad we had
some discussions as well on this subject
matter
briefly and um yeah just one of those
things like you know I'm I'm not gonna
loud
you ready way to talk about games gaming
saved me and a lot of my friends like
Saturday used to be like you come over
the Lord [ __ ] needles place and you know
it was it was escape to get away from
the drama that was around us what was
going on in between those walls Tekken's
so it's good to see it's absolutely good
to see so we gonna move on I'm gonna
jump on into my topic here so I'm so
wrong as going on right now looks like
what yo the Nintendo switch it looks
like there's a there's an industry
inside this guy he's been dropping some
nuggets in the past name is Marcus
sellers he's on Twitter he's a good
follow and basically he has predicted
some things in the past he had predicted
uh leave Call of Duty coming in a switch
and a couple of a little league so
caliber six he was one of the first to
be ahead of that so he just dropped some
bombshells entertaining to the switch
and the first one was Diablo 3 you know
he was saying that there's definitely a
switch port coming he's saying it should
be out early 2019
he said they want to implement local
play and with multiple switches and then
what I thought was the bomb show was for
tonight he's saying that he says like
fortnight schools Nintendo ships short
switch and he's like a battle royal will
be the perfect match there's no doubt
about it so I wanted to bring this to
the round table in reference to
fortnight obviously we know right now at
fortnight specifically there's a huge
update right now it's looking fantastic
moving at 60 frames per second pretty
much on all the platforms and what do
you think how that would go for the
switch if this is true as well at the
Diablo 3 ports so uh Lord dude and then
Lord cradles what do you think about
this well um Lord Kratos is gone but
that's all
the locator for cover do you know it's
this is one of the issues I have with
this switch like I love the switch okay
don't get me wrong I played through
Celeste
I love certain games on the switch Mario
vs. rabbits it's a fantastic game switch
awesome game on the switch when I hear
about games like Diablo 3 awesome game
you think about here about fortnight
awesome game but these are games that
are obviously little bit older already
not for tonight so much but there these
are games that run infinitely better on
the PlayStation 4 on the Xbox one and
the one game I'm gonna look at real
quick is payday 2 the switch this week
and man just receiving uh nyah waited
right now for being up not only for
being behind it updates the PC and the
other console versions but because of
the lack of voice chair how can you have
any of you played payday 2 solo how can
you not there's no voice chat okay so if
you try to play payday 2 solo that game
is just garbage you're AI absolutely
useless so I don't want to play that and
then if I want to play cooperatively a
game that requires communication I mean
H I like communication and you can't
even do that
payday 2 is dead on arrival it's the
older version yes it's not even the most
up-to-date version of the game like
that's inexcusable overkill already had
a bad reputation for not supporting
console versions frequently there's been
uproars if you look at like the forest
people don't trust overkill and they
were screaming like we want to wait and
see with the switch version and sure
enough it's just like you said older
version no voice yet but continue but
see like and then you know I look at
that and then I look at the recently
announced Dark Souls remastered okay
yeah they call it out there like hey
it's coming this way shake oh cool and
then you find out it's coming to
PlayStation 4 and Xbox we're like Oh 4k
60 frames Diablo 3 and fortnight if
those are all coming and those are gonna
be the same situations but Nintendo has
to figure out the system to make those
games appeal
it's going to be very difficult to play
Diablo 3 and not be able to communicate
unless you're all sitting together but I
mean a my age I don't have time to drive
down to Ohio to see Frankie pick up pick
up pick up on my way down just to do
some local stuff so we can talk to each
other don't chat don't want to play it
for tonight if there's no Chet I don't
want to play it and obviously there's no
way that runs at 60 frames and you
already had the optimal version on
another console it's just very difficult
to bring these games out a year later
and have any real appeal especially if
they're gonna charge the price they're
gonna charge from we don't know those
prices are but I'm pretty sure we'll
have some some high prices there for
these games so it's just it's very
difficult to get excited about these
games on the switch even though it's a
cool concept so many of the needed
features to enjoy these games are absent
right no this is this is valid valid
points lost some start with you what do
you what do you think about all this dis
Diablo 3 and then actually is one more I
forgot that actually Marcus L especially
near automata yes what do you feel
fortnight Diablo 3 possible disguise he
has some history has not been all wrong
he's not barking up the wrong tree those
games and here's a single-player game
Diablo 3 can be played single-player or
worries me about that gavel 3 on that
form factor if you're playing it in
handheld mode is that the isometric kind
of type of game in a handheld mode is a
little weird too it can potentially be
too small for the screen and so stuff
like that um but like piggyback in the
world or dude said yeah I think the
thing about it is the only thing that is
exciting about these games and I said it
before like when it came to doom on the
switch and Wolfenstein whenever it comes
out this year on a switch the
portability is the only thing that that
that sort of makes that game makes it an
exciting proposition
because at this point we have no idea
what their online is we have no idea
what they're planning
like no key key machine we came out and
said that like you're really gonna be
excited by what we do with this stuff
and I'm like wait a minute yeah but you
know makes sense if they if they can get
it you know it the art style is such
that it it shouldn't be super taxing
it's obviously gonna run at 30 frames
per second and again if you can release
that game with some sort of concrete
indication of how you're gonna handle
online true online that local
multiplayer that ad-hoc multiplayer not
you know not not using your phone app to
communicate it this is the game that
they utilize to really push what your
online is gonna be and it works great
I think it's I think it's absolutely
possible oh but you know they gotta show
it
they gotta show it I'm what y'all
jumping right quick um yeah I think it's
what I think for tonight in particular
just from the art style of the game and
I could kind of see like a cel-shaded
kind of you know colorful it kind of
fits a Nintendo style game in my opinion
um but like you guys said you know all
this is mutant and relevant if the
online infrastructure is not in place
you know and like Lord dude said he's
not traveling down you know
to get these powwows of land parties
going that's not happening people not
doing it so the reality is I think and
what I'm hoping is a shout out to a
spawn wave or media good file or good
podcast what I'm hoping is they finally
have way
it's the white flag on that damn app and
they realize the engagement numbers are
not there you know I don't even think
people you play splatoon are using that
app is only for one game so I think
ultimately it comes down to they have to
have that thing in place you know
because at the end of the day you can't
charge $20 for what you currently have
existing so it has to be something it
has to be either messaging has to be 4-h
voice chat across but one would hope now
if that's the case if these things
launch alongside but the I would be
launched alongside of a fortnight
launched alongside this new
infrastructure now we did hear what was
the date we heard for the infrastructure
was it September 20th something like
that now the rumor that sellers is
saying for fortnight is September August
last September and if it's again if it
lines up that would be a perfect launch
title for there said service if they
have the proper protocols and
infrastructure in place that's the
question with grandpa intended we never
know what they gonna do so yeah I mean
that that's the whole you know I just
like I said Diablo I think is another
good good fit for the system know near
again all this stuff sounds great
I just want intended to get things set
up the def sings of it sell it a little
pull us a so do you copy Xbox Phil is
inclusive right now he's very protocols
going you know and let's go let's do it
look you know you could have an
interesting take they don't have the
game get the game who cares if you can't
if that's the only way to play that game
I don't care if it's an inferior version
if it's your only way to play that game
and you want to play that game then play
that game you can take the system you
made a choice deal with it I don't care
if it's a 4k resolution version maybe
you don't even have a 4k TV so it
doesn't matter Oh where's the superior
version
it's about where you game and how you
play so if you're having fun where you
plan and how you game and do it the
numbers indicate that they're selling to
somebody the numbers he said Mario and
Mario Kart is still the top sellers
Zelda came out a year some change ago
come on now
yeah you really got to think about it
this way if that game is still selling
in that in that fashion they have a
dedicated audience that is happy and
it's thriving
so why would we discourage that and if
I'm a developer I'm trying to figure out
how the hell can I trim the fat off of
my game to get it there yes to those
people so don't be upset with the fact
that they're getting games we have said
that you that you get you don't have a
bigger install base I guess I don't know
which ports are selling well so you know
why not accommodate it why not get this
infrastructure in place and then really
take off and actually like I said last
week you appeal to the hardcore that
that DS that's the only thing is
preventing the hardcore from jumping in
on the switches right now it's more of a
casual thing and in research time you
know if you throw that in some quest
message in some achievements in a voice
chat that's it that's all that's right
all after 20 bucks let's go I hope so
I really do always find a way they got
you playing with cardboard I just wanna
say I just want to say I dig what Lord
King is saying if that's the only system
you're playing on yes buy some of those
games accept payday 2 don't let friends
play payday 2 alarm no party chat and an
old version King you got your tablet
we're gonna try to power through it
along the day but was just great
discussions chat has been fantastic we
had to get cradles it here so Lord King
which you got going on with a the Xbox
one X all right shout out to everybody
that has brought an X right you know you
got an extra
shiny new EX you like whoo baby I want
to drive this car
all right any time you get a new
anything I don't care what it is if it's
a laptop Hey is it new you putting your
old games wanted to see how better it
runs you still look at that graphics
card go baby you sit there with your
hands in your pocket how many times have
you ran benchmarks just just measure of
sticks we do it mom I think it's about
time that Microsoft and I think the game
Pass is a great platform for us to start
to exercise that power when I'm not
liking across the boards is you see
games are being released on PlayStation
and Pro and there's some weird parry
like the games hey rain clothes are the
same the only thing that's different is
the shrubbery over here I think oh I
don't want to see the Pinto in the end
I'm not on the highway doing 55 with the
Pinto I'm not doing that the Pinto can't
go past 55 but I can so stop holding me
back
so only first thing that can do that
because you know developers aren't so
nice old so that's going to be the lead
platform and then push it down that way
and they can only go as high as they're
gonna let's do some revolution bump over
a little more frames per second let's
put that dead is that be happy with that
no I'm not happy with that
nothing has said that Pinto fired oh
yeah II like his Pinto 120 in the fast
lane I want to be in the fast time I
don't want to be here this is are you
all right I want to be in the fast lane
you should not be look I should not see
you in my rearview carry you should not
be close to me and what Microsoft is
this right being that you know we have
game past we have a preview program do
you think that is time for Microsoft to
start putting high-end PC
because there's all inclusive game
passes all inclusive um and high-end
Xbox X only games in the preview program
and inside game pass cos it's free hmm
to show you the strength of your system
to show you the possibilities of the
world with them maximizing the power of
the system instead of it being shackled
and held back and only used for up
rezzing and frame boosting mmm nor dude
what do you think about this what you
what's your take you know it's it's
funny because you mentioned that and you
think about Nintendo for a moment with
the 3ds you know that they have the new
3d yes and there's certain games that
only run on the new 3ds and nobody's mad
about that that's a good then when you
start talking about the ex regno no no
no Microsoft said this is all one of the
part one a part of the same it's all one
of the same it's all part of the same
family so we have to keep things sort of
close but now Mike Ibarra is out there
saying no we don't for enforce any
parody yeah here's my thought I you know
when the ps4 Pro is announced you know
everyone was like well they got to keep
things in parity you know and that's
because the pro while it's a boost it's
not substantial I mean it's not a huge
boost whereas if you look at the X okay
that's a $500 system with a beefy engine
under the hood okay this thing can do
some serious work if it wants to I think
it's a little bit easier for Xbox fans
specifically those that just have an
Xbox one next to say hey look I want
better stuff and I get that because hey
I have an Xbox one I would love to see
the best I want to get the most out of
my system it's a little bit easier for
owners say oh that's ok it's ok if
they're the same but man when you own an
X and you've paid the extra hundred
dollars over the pro and you look at the
specs on that thing
I am not opposed to to getting a beefed
up game that's X Y a I hey what you
going in what what do you feel or dude
about the memo when Brandon green got
was they got in trouble well remember
you know the announcement he was like oh
yeah the ex can do 60 frames no problem
and he made that statement and it was
like kind of a lady retract meant like
oh we don't have nothing to comment on
on the version
like what did you feel was a lot of
uproar we did an ILP about that whole
episode it was very peculiar I believe
us when we had potentially perfect and
um yeah it was it was a number well I we
had to do a poll and the poll you know
eventually the people who said the X Box
when X should not be held back one that
poll mm-hmm but um I just wanted you to
like what did you feel about that whole
fiasco Brandon Green came out you know
it was it was amusing to watch everyone
get mad about it and and I can
understand why because there's this
there's this misconception that if you
play a 60 frame game against somebody
was playing a 30 frame game there's this
huge disadvantage but I mean we've all
heard it before I mean if you're playing
a PC there are people playing the games
at 7:20 barely 30 going up against
people going 1080p60 and they're doing
they're doing fine they've been doing
this for a long time right but I
understand though consoles are all the
same you know and you try to keep
everyone on a level playing field that's
always the hardest part with consoles
because everyone's buying the same
system but the ax fox one X is not the
same as the Xbox one it's much stronger
so I mean I guess they could try doing
something like a trial to see how it
does and see how it fares but it's going
to be a slippery slope for Microsoft
because you know they initially said
this is all part of the Xbox one family
so they you know for them to go back and
say look you know well out will do Xbox
one exclusive they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna get some blowback
from especially from the original Xbox
one owners who have not upgraded for
whatever reason maybe it's Harper it's
hard for a lot of gamers to have one
system big ok I'm gonna go out by the
$500 that's just not feasible for a lot
of people and I can understand why those
people would be upset about because they
were told from the start don't worry
about it right but at the same time you
don't hey man I paid $500 for this
system this Saturday you tell I want to
see some good stuff I understand both
sides of the argument it's a very
slippery slope for Microsoft absolutely
loss off yeah I think I mean
fundamentally of course I agree with
King like I want the best I could
possibly get out of my $500 system but
like Lord Duke said like it's a slippery
slope because they made all these
promises about what their ecosystem is
and how it's going to be handled so it's
it
would be hard to go back on that right
it may be considered flip-flopping if
they went back on that and figured out
some way to just give X exclusive stuff
that's one part of it another part of
the argument that I have a little bit of
trouble with and I've always had trouble
with this is the fact that the
perception that games obviously if you
make a game specifically for one
platform you're gonna be able to
maximize that platform to the fullest
right mm-hmm but again I think that
games now you know we've been seeing
this on the PC front forever games have
always been created with scalability in
mind and I don't see the problem with
creating a game that runs a certain way
on base Xbox and runs considerably
better with better textures but or
lighting but all this on the X I mean
it's been happening to that whole
perception about like the game can only
be better if it's created specifically
for that platform I don't like that
because it's just that's not how gaming
has been for a long time you know steam
I just wanna I want to reinforce what
you're saying so you're you're saying
like you you you don't want that whole
mentality or you don't subscribe to that
theory of where you at with with a big
when it comes to the Kings point like to
a base X game we would add I think you
know I think they have to be created the
games have to be created with the
specific hardware in mind I think it's
fine to create a base game and have it
scalable so that it looks as good as it
can on a base Xbox one and as good as it
can on an Xbox one X I I don't subscribe
to the argument that because it wasn't
created specifically for the X oh it's
being held back because again like I
said games have been created games have
been created this way for the longest
time when you look at a game on on the
PC you low-end pcs gonna show a certain
games run away and then you put a ten
atti and then the game you look
completely different I'm talking about a
game that doesn't even run on that the
regular I'm just talking about a testing
ground for Xbox one X specific titles
and high-end PC titles you're talking
about from a Mac pure maximization
standard B
only you won't push the limit yeah I
would love to see that again another
reason why again fundamentally I agree
with it another reason why I think from
the logistical standpoint that is not
happening is this like when they when
they finally announce the name of the
Xbox one X right this is past easy right
they admitted that they had only gotten
deaf kids into developers hands maybe
six months before and that not all
developers had them yet so they were
still getting deaf kids out there right
so if you just look at time frame but
mystically it'd be hard to get a game
that was created from the ground up with
the X in mind this year even next year
so then if you're looking at you know
2024 a game that was built with the X in
mind I think at that point we're already
talking about what's next for Xbox right
we're not talking about we're not
talking about the X anymore we're
talking about whatever is next at that
point so I think just logistically it'd
be hard to get that done right if
anybody could do it is Microsoft with
their properties right if they really
yes they really put the effort into it
but I just think as it from an overall
maybe a third-party perspective would be
harder to see that happen mmm fair
enough
I mean this is a good interesting topic
I mean you know Lord King I know he's
been even pushed to the limit and you
know it's kind of interesting because
like like our Lord said like would Mikey
borrowers tweet I mean he had and he
said cuz somebody was like yeah it's
unfair that the axis being held back and
he's like I don't know what you're
talking about we do not require any
parity in terms of s for X this is it is
I see some most more arguments I see the
slippery slope argument but at the same
time if they're making state statements
like this then you know I would the way
I look at the way they're treating it to
me feels like the elite controller the
exercise controller so you know you have
all these thing like you got your elite
you've got the paddles in the back
you've got your triggers but you got all
these fundamental advantages over a
standard gamer your exam so my thing is
they are not the vibe I'm getting from
them is that they are not looking to
hold it back I don't know I do agree
with solved those I don't know if
they're gonna grow there
route with the you know bass xbox 1x
game only because as Lord King hates the
tiki torches will come out the bass want
let's be honest the bass X crowd is
still the majority you don't like Lord
at it and those guys I could see the
rage come void you know you guys we're
not the game is free in game PES we're
not preclude you from playing the game
but you know you don't have to do
anything you can look from afar they
have videos or you to praise e we do
this with everything in his life right
you got a side of the store to buy jeans
right I didn't know that there was jeans
that was $400 I'm honestly telling him
this I did not notice right because my
that's not where I shop right so my
grocery store and I'm going to get a
pair jeans and he's like oh these these
jeans is over here these days is over
here so I'm like oh those things is nice
let me get this I'm good my size and
trying to more he did not say the price
scoop put her on the counter and he said
$400 I said oh I don't I don't need 4
pair of jeans I just need the one okay
you can take that back you can give me
the ones that are normal gene prices now
if you can't shop there there are things
in this world that you can't afford you
don't be upset about it that you can't
afford it you just can't afford it they
are there you can admire them you can't
expire to them when
we play now we have the X crowd and we
have the simps and we have the right now
when the old G's jump in they are loaded
in this is horrible for them we gotta
guard the bodies sometimes when they're
lagging out yeah you know runs horribly
flawed and then that's not the self
version the silk version the simp is a
little bit better here a little bit
better and you're telling them yo is a
guy over there on 20 yards out at 56
South and he's like I don't see him hold
on it just popping it shout out to the
whole team that has graduated to Eric
shout-out to Vogel here to actually say
this night and day no I you have to
inspire the things right and I seen a
lot of things in for everyone what I'm
saying is for those people who did put
out um what about those people know yeah
just put games in game pass because this
some games in game pass I will never
touch it has absolutely nothing to do
from a performance standpoint it's just
a game taste standpoint maybe that game
is in there that shows me why I have an
ex that's all I don't care if it's a
test demo put demos in it I don't care
just show me what I said Sam is about
the roll on you with your og system the
big fat one the one that look like a VCR
or what it is cell right leave me with
that dick
legit arguments on both sides as far as
not being held back so it will be
interesting to see what happens in the
future if they even decide but says they
probably won't you know say they don't
want the backlash wait for the next
generation we'll see we'll see if the
Pinto freedom get eliminated new people
this week with the recent rumors of a
possible relationship with Microsoft and
Sega of Japan what do you think is the
best course of action for Xbox the
choices are a purchase Sega outright for
its in-house exclusives B partner would
say go only for select IPS or C I don't
care unless Shenmue 3 is part of the
deal please Rock the Vote and hit the
ILP Twitter polls when it goes up most
likely tomorrow nor dude an absolute
pleasure to have you at the realm at the
roundtable weight can define people find
you what's going on with the short pause
get you first off I got to buy one of
these tables okay seriously you can find
me on Twitter at the dude 1979 the
website is wo Paz calm we're also on
Twitter at the short pause the short
pause gaming podcast is on iTunes tune
in Google Play stitcher SoundCloud the
latest episode will be going up tonight
I'll be going I got to get to work out
as soon as I get done here so it later
tonight
it's also on YouTube twitch and on our
facebook page short pause gaming I just
want to give a shout out one quick shout
out to the guys at short pause bend
voice every cool 9:30 yeah
Anke allure ad viper strike better halt
at banner or underscore guitar and has
me at Taz pause these guys are just
highly motivated highly ambitious guys
and honestly short pause won't be a
thing without them these guys come to
work every Saturday night they do their
job in the podcast they stream during
the week there were few games when we
get them in a timely manner these guys
are dedicated and and I honestly uh I'm
in that to them forever
I actually love these guys they're
fantastic workers I love spending every
waking night playing destiny too with
them or other games but seriously add to
those four guys shouts I love you guys
very much you guys are the best
absolutely it we definitely want to
reiterate you know definitely wanna
shout them out like you said viper
strike bender that man on the guitar
Laura piccolo you know the secret Lord
that it's behind the shadows tears
mirror he's only shells all right that's
the man right that's the minute makes it
happy a shout-out to you guys we see the
dedication we see the streams you know
you're constantly doing you know in the
spotlights and Let's Plays and very
active positive in the community and we
want to give those grat forms light man
and you know me and you Lord do been
talking for a while just working out the
schedule in and I'm so happy to finally
get you in the realm of the Lord's it's
been a pleasure I mean you guys are
seriously awesome to listen to it's even
better to be able to sit down here and
have a talk with you guys you guys you
guys are one of the best podcasts out
there for this community you do great
things you bring the community together
you don't separate it and we appreciate
you guys very much and I love listening
to your show so keep please keep doing
what you're doing making this community
community a better place much appreciate
we make a huge thing to us means a lot
man thank you so much Lord addict Lord
had to turn into Lord sleep double shift
today about sleepers return but he sent
me a message he doesn't want anyone to
be rude know what happened Lord saw
where can they find people not find you
online
first of all yeah shoutouts a lawyer
dude man fantastic conversation it's
always good to have a lord of our age
group come on yes they can relate to our
Sega stories that are
old story so fantastic having you on man
and yeah the people could not find me
Xbox Live and PSN @bx sovereign but you
can't find me dying a whole lot on
switch that's our offline profile
Illuminati this exam Lord King the
excess non Pinto dude I am so happy you
know you're on the podcast today it's
very refreshing um like I said talking
to people of the same like mine
inclusive not exclusive type of
mentality you came from the ground up
well you said in television I was like
that was oh geez daddy's we do that
dazzle yes we have a different type of
patience when it comes to things we
don't feel entitled for stuff because we
came from actual blocks we thought it
wasn't even a ball it was a smaller
block the struggle is real with us and I
understand I respect it I love
everything that everyone's doing um
kognito shot me the podcast last night
so I can refresh myself at you guys
podcast I actually found it very
entertaining hugely entertaining um so I
appreciate you coming through I
appreciate you giving the time and
energy and and it was worth it it was
definitely worth it because it was a
great podcast um where you guys can find
me Instagram Twitter Facebook uh y'all
really think I'm trolling
I'm not trolling oh please the network
is Xbox 360 love our home
I'm a Chico but also I'm approachable
everybody in this chat knows I'm highly
approachable
I'm not standoffish I'm the king of the
people baby get them streams go Abed
today we stream it with streaming today
we tried that streaming a couple of
weeks ago with me braaap and so on and
brad had the PG on his filter we told up
here to cut that out because yes this
was the king that you just saw before
the cameras went off redneck gaming reel
this on the io feed not tell you what
you would have let what you need to hear
thanks again lord dude coming through of
the short path quite as fast gaming
network oh man
such a fun show today shout to all law
cradles ever coming through last really
that was actually fun we gonna get him
or both your vide and you both clown the
others it's funny so people were like I
had to do it I was like people don't
believe that baby people there was a
rumor going around an emergency D of
just to get it to prove that you don't
have everybody you know saying this show
support yeah and really preach at was
absolutely lit today we got a lot of
stuff cooking up on thank you for the
support on flashpoints I know destiny is
dead but um you know me any boxes we
keepin the torch running on the iron law
podcast and we'll have another episode
up probably this Thursday we're trying
to get it locked in between 7 and 8 p.m.
we were doing doing that going on and
yeah man please support the laws and
everything we do we'll have the audio
and all that good stuff
and the multi-verse will be up tomorrow
believe at 8:00 p.m. and also I believe
the Phoenix Park has be on the lookout
for them they've got some stuff cooking
up they will be the new addition to the
inner circle network they got really
cool stuff going on yeah man shout out
to those guys got a chance to chat with
them offline they look really positive
and really good like hardcore comic book
you know and anime and all that good
stuff over there yeah like they've got
it poppin it you know we're talking
about like greatest villain stuff like
that I think I threw kill monger or
they're like okay we gotta have another
show like the entire MCU that kind of
stuff no yeah of course of course we
just we just shoot it you know it was
just fun positive stuff man so yeah man
thank you for all just what thank you
for the chat everybody enjoy their
Sunday and on that note yeah I did
hunters for life